china's overt might is clear to sea
but its secretive activities are
starting to attract more attention
it's why the heads of mi5 and the fbi
use their first ever joint public speech
to raise the alarm
the most game-changing challenge we face
comes from the chinese communist party
it's covertly applying pressure across
the globe
this might feel abstract but it's real
and it's pressing
we need to talk about it
we need to act
china's accused of hacking and stealing
secrets to get ahead in areas like
technology and medicine
the security chief said it also uses
coercion and corruption to spread
influence and ideas
cyberspace a big battlefield
of course russia's war in ukraine and
the wider russian threat is a major
focus for officials at mi5 and at the
fbi but it's the sheer breadth and scale
of the challenge posed by china that's
causing such concern with targets
ranging from university students and
local politicians to giant corporations
and national governments
mi5 is doubling its efforts to combat
chinese spying
if we don't respond
this will have a dramatic impact on our
nations businesses can't be competitive
if chinese farms are copying their work
beijing's intentions over taiwan are
also a key issue
here taiwanese tanks on exercises amid
fears beijing may try to take the island
by force
the fbi director said the chinese
authorities are drawing lessons from the
west's response to russia's invasion of
ukraine including the impact of
sanctions
we've seen china looking for ways to
insulate their economy against potential
sanctions trying to cushion themselves
from harm if they do anything to draw
the ire
of the international community
now in our world we call that kind of
behavior
a clue
the fact these two want to talk about
china in such stark terms is also a clue
of sorts
debra haynes sky news